okay I guess uh let's get started
um let's see is this working yes
um so I guess so
um last time we have talked about
answering and today we're going to
continue with Express learning
um
so I guess
so and first we're going to continue
with the moment method
and here we're going to talk about
higher
other moment
and then next we're going to talk about
some
thing called clustering or special
classroom in more
technical course
um so these are different type of
instructional algorithms
so I guess just to continue with the
what you had last time last time we
ended up this mix of cautions
the setup was that you have some X which
is sampled from a mixture of cake
gaussians
with me new I and covariance identity
and
so at last time I think at the beginning
we talked about you know case two we
have two mixture of Two gaussians And in
the
in that special case you can just pick
the second moment of the Belgian to
recover the new eyes and then we move
down to talk about case on bigger than
two and in that case we have argued that
if you take the second mixture right if
you take the second moment
then this is something like one over K
times sum of mu y muy transpose and this
is not enough
to recover new
eyes because you know given this second
moment you uh still cannot identify the
new eyes precisely because there are
multiple mineralized that can make
perhaps the same second moment
so so so that motivates us to uh
consider the third moment
so the third moment is
as we discussed is the expectation of X
tensor X tensor X so this is the third
order sensor in dimension
d by D by D and let's compute what's the
third moment and with the hope that the
third moment will tell us enough about
new eyes where we can recover
um mu eyes from the third moment and
that's indeed the case so what we do
here is the following so we compute the
third moment and I guess the
the initial step is always the same
because you have a mix of K clusters so
you do what you do is you have one over
K times the sum of the moment
conditioned on each of the cluster I
where I is the
cluster ID
and now the question becomes that if you
have a gaussian drawn from if you have
an X drawn from gaussian then what's the
third moment What's the expectation of
third moment right so what is this uh
expectation of X tends to X tensor X
conditional I
so
um so let's do some kind of like a
simplification just to this is an
abstraction in some sense so that we can
make the notation simpler so suppose
Z is from some gaussian with mu mean
that's called a
is to distinguish it from the
a and cover Converse identity
then the question is what is
you have this Lemma
um I guess the condition is this and
then
our question is what is the expectation
of Z times or Z answer z
and the claim is that this is
pretty much
equals to A tensor a tensor a but with
some caveats there's some other terms
which are something like this let me
write it down and explain so this is L
from 1 to D expectation of x
tensor
El tensor elf
Plus
from the expectation
El tensor expectation X
foreign
ER oh sorry my right this is not X this
is z
there's no X in this level we already
changed our notation to Z
um
so so know that
expectation of Z is really literally a
so basically you have already have a
formula that expresses the third moment
of Z into a function of a right that
makes sense because everything a decides
everything so everything at the end of
this should be a function of a right so
the reason why we still use EZ in this
formula is because we want to implicitly
say that you know this is something
or it is something that is about the
first moment so maybe the the more
important thing is that
this means that
you can you can compute
so we can compute
a tensor a tensor a from
linear combinations
in terms of inner combinations
of the third moment and this first
moment
why it's useful to get this I think this
will be clear why it's used for the get
a tensori tensor a
um it's useful
um or we'll see it in a moment
but the the dyslema tells you that if
you know the first moment and third
moment you can get a tensor a tensor a
um from sorry I keep messing up with the
light right here so here is the c
foreign
Okay so
and
see
I think I would any questions so far
I guess you know it's not exactly clear
why this Lemma is useful
you know at the current point I guess
the main point is that you can compute
out with the third or third moment when
Z is just a gaussian and I think the
proof I'm gonna show the proof I think
the proof is you know nothing super
interesting but it tells you how to do
this kind of the derivations for the
moment and once you see it once then all
the others becomes you know uh kind of
trivial so how do you compute the third
moment so what you do is you do it
forever aren't you
so you say you look at the ijk entry of
this thing then this is just expectation
z i z j z k where z i denotes the
coordinates the ith coordinates
and
um
I think there's something
sorry for the notetakers I think uh I
changed my rotation to V here
just to be consistent
I mean
my back
since this will be it's just a generic
variable it's just a somehow later I use
V so let's change this to V
so
um
so what we do is that we just uh you
know to compute this moment which is the
and sometimes do this in a Brute Force
way right so what is what is the icjck
you can write z i mean v i plus some
casilla
and z v j c j can be v j plus T J
and z k v k Plus
CK this is we are using a factor Z as a
vector is equal to V plus some C where C
is from
spherical question that's that's my
definition of Casino sometimes because C
is equal to Z minus V and which has you
know spherical gaussian
um uh description
and then you can and V by the way VR is
the ith current just to to be clear
so and then we can expand this so there
are eight terms in this product so so
what are them so one of the term is v i
v j v k that's easy V is deterministic
because C Is Random right and some of
the terms will look like expectation
v i
v j c k well the term is this another
term is expectation v i
v k equals c j and plus expectation
v j v k equals c i
and these terms will be equals to zero
because you know the expectation of
cursing is zero and V is a deterministic
quantity so that's why they are going to
be zero
and then we have the other three terms
that looks like expectation VI because
CJ because CK
plus expectation V J equals c i equals
CK
plus expectation v k equals c i equals
CJ
so these terms is a little bit different
let me deal with it
in a moment and this last type of term
is the product of the three courses
so
how do we deal with the the rest of the
four terms so the thing is that if you
look at expectation you can see I could
see k
this is equals to what this is equals to
zero if I is not equal to K because if
it's equal to I is not equal to a
because c i c k are two independent
random variables and you can factorize
it to get expectation for C and plus c k
they're both zero so you get zero and
this is one if I is equal to K because
okay maybe let's have more steps so this
is equals to expectation because the I
squared
which is equals to 1 if I is equals to K
so
so in summary expectation of because C I
could see K is equals to
indicator
that I is equals to K
and you can also try to do deal with CI
because C J Co clay and here you can
still you know try to do the same thing
like try to divide different cases
whether ijp are all the same or maybe
both two of the I and J's are the same
and K is different there are a few cases
and actually if you knew in all of those
cases it turns out that it's always zero
like regardless of regardless of
the choice of ijk
but for different reasons right for
example when ijk
are all the same and this is the third
power of CI so it's equals to
expectation because c i cubed and that's
zero because
gaussian the third moment of gaussian is
zero and and when I is equal to J and Y
naught equals to hey you can do another
different you know calculation but
generally you can do all of calculations
and they are equal to zero it sometimes
I think the reason fundamental reasons
that as long as you have
even your exams have all degree
polynomial but not all degree monomial
of this classy eyes
it doesn't matter like it's always going
to be zero the expectation is going to
always not be zero
so so these are all in sometimes
Elementary calculations and then if you
use this then you can continue here you
can get this is expect equals to v i v j
v k plus VI times the indicator J is
equals to K plus v j and this greater I
is equal to K plus v k indicator
I is equals to J
and and this is pretty much complete the
proof so then you just have to rewrite
this
you know on your tester form so if you
verify I guess how do you write it I
guess
if you verify this equation the target
equation
entry by entry then you see that this is
exactly exactly
um
same
so this is VL
help us
all right so so this is our Target
equation this is what we got
for every entry
so let's just verify these two you know
verify that they are they are they are
the same thing it's just a
reorganization so
um how do you verify that it's kind of
like if you take the ijk coordinates do
you see that
so the question is what this what the
ijk card of this guy is right so V
tensor El tensor El
the ijk coordinate
is equals to it always has a VI there
because you know VI is always there
but the J the JK coordinate of this
El and El depends on so basically you
have to this is the only possibility is
that this is e
so the only possibility that so
basically this is like
I guess maybe one way to write this is
that if you really do it
this is V
I
times El the J is quantity of elf
and e l the K is quantity of EO
right
so and in what case this the J
coordinate of el and K Corner are both
non-zero
the only case is that
L is equals to J and IO is equals to K
that's the only case that this can be
non-zero so that's why this is equals to
v i times y when L is equal to J L is
equals square and the only way this this
can happen is that J is equals to K
right
When J is equals to K otherwise it's
going to be zero
so that's how you verified you know the
the I don't I don't expect you to kind
of verify completely you know on the fly
but you know in some sense the exact
formula doesn't matter that much either
way you only need to have a formula that
depends on the times third moment of v
and also some like formula basically you
just need a formula for B okay so so any
questions so far
so now let's see how we use it right so
how we use it is the following so and
you can kind of see
um what kind of things we exactly need
so you need so now you look at the X
right X is a mixture of gaussians Z was
only a single God
and you use this single gaussian thing
uh on them
the single gaussian has a building block
to compute the moment of the mix of
gaussians
and what you do is that okay when
condition I becomes a gaussian and you
apply the the lemon and you get 1 over K
times
sum over I from 1 to K and then this is
Mu I tensor
mean y times the MU I because mu I is
taking the place of V
and then you have
the additional three terms
mu I transfer e l tensor e l
and El tensor mu I
transfer El
Plus
e l tensor EO
UI
Okay so
um parenthesis
okay so and
so basically the the third moment of X
is a function of mu I's it's still a
little bit messy so what you do is you
say I'm going to get rid of all of these
terms
by using the first moment that's the
first and the the moment reflects right
so so what you do is that you first
reorganize a little bit you get
this somewhat cleanly looking term mu
eye tensor meanwhile tensor mu I
and then you
switch the K with the the two sums for
the rest of three terms you get sum over
l
from 1 to D
1 over K times sum over I from 1 to D mu
I
tensor El tensor El
and we have the the two other terms
which I guess
you can't really you can imagine what
they look like they just their
permutations there are rotations of
these terms in something changing the
order and now this one
because becomes the first moment of x
so you get one over three
you'll get the same this is I sorry this
is I
foreign
something that depends on the first one
of x
right so what does this mean is that you
can move this
three things
to the left hand side
right so so basically this means that we
can compute
this tensor
from
the third moment
and the first moment
so
that's basically our interface right
once you have this tensor then the next
step will be
Next Step
so we'll go from here so from
this thing I guess let me write this I
think I should have introduced this to
mewise
so I'm that's just a funnel notation no
purpose so a to the 10th through three
is just a short time for a
times a tensor a
so basically
what what this you know what the whole
this whole computation is saying is that
now you can compute this
expected there's a sum of the third
moment of email I and then you need to
design algorithm
to compute the MU X from this
and and if you can do this in your
question mark then you you're done the
whole thing is soft
because because you can first use the
moment to compute the third order the
third tensor from your eyes and then you
can run this algorithm
um there are some you know there are
actually some cleaner ways to deal with
this we don't have to deal with this
additional terms you know to get there
are some other ways to get this exact
Federal tensor it's directly in a
cleaner way
um but that requires a little bit other
Machinery so so that's why I'm kind of
like only using this relatively Brute
Force ways to get the third element but
the point is that you can always get
some something like this so so now the
problem becomes this so-called tensor
decolonization problem
So abstractly speaking this tensor
decomposition problem is something like
you
so abstractly
you have a sequence of vectors A1 up to
a n these are all in dimension okay in
our Dimension B so these are unknown
and which are given
is a vector
that looks like this right from 1 to K
and then your goal
is to reconstruct
AIS
Le and you can also ask about this you
know for different orders of tensors you
can also ask the same question you know
um
questions
also for for example you can have
some other odds or the tensor for some
art that is bigger the possibly bigger
than three
and it turns out that you can also get
the 4.10 the first order kind of power
From This Moment method right if you
take the fourth moment of the Dayton you
can get ah the tensor four you know with
some real Arrangement like like that
so so basically this is the the kind of
the
um
um the kind of interfaces right you you
basically reduce the moment you reduce
the answering problem to this so-called
tested conversation problem
and this tensor decomposition problem
also has certain kind of like
some was kind of like a
um let me also give you some Notions for
this threshold notation so
um this
so the the rank of the tensor
so some basic
notion
so the rank
um so I guess let's say
a tensor B tensor C is a rank one tensor
this is the definition for background
tensor and then the rank of a tensor k
uh tensor t
is the minimum
K such that
T can be
written
as
a sum of rock one a sum of K
Ron tensors
sometimes this is also called CPT
conversations
so in some sense like the re the reason
why this conversation is that you
observe this you know some of these rank
one intenses you want to decompose it
into components and each component is
referred
so and and this question is sometimes
called CP decomposition because there
are some other decompositions for tensor
that could also be meaningful in other
cases
um
um but but actually you know it's also
fun to just call it tested accommodation
because this is the the men the most
popular decomposition for cancers
okay so
um okay so now because okay so I guess
so
um now it becomes a very uh modularized
question it's algorithmic question right
how do you figure out
uh the components uh from given a low
ranked answer how do you figure out the
lower end components
so I'm going to
um what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to basically list some of the
existing results but not really talking
about details because this is a actually
what happens you know in this area you
know I think this error becomes kind of
like very popular around 2013 2012.
um and in the very beginning I think a
few papers
um kind of lay out the framework for
this kind of Hosting right so how do you
complete the moment how to convert it
into tested conversation problem
and then those papers provide some some
easy tensor conversation problem or they
actually invoke some of the existing
tensor decomposition problems and that's
those the early papers and then
um this field you know somewhere kind of
like a
this question becomes two parts right
one part is about how do you do the
movement but how do you turn the
movement into a tensor and then the
second part is how to decompose the
tensor so so people have you know there
are a lot of papers you know involving
some of my works as well you know but
there are actually a lot of works that
uh tries to understand how do you
decompose all different kind of tensors
like when the word conventions you can
you can decompose
so so maybe so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to list a few conditions that
you can decompose these tensors you know
um uh um computational efficiently and
and those conditions you will turn into
a condition for the Upstream problem
for example in a mix of gaussian
problems gonna have some conditions so
um just to set up the the kind of the
kind of the basis
um
let me see where I wrote this
is
this so the maybe the number zero is
that in in the in the most General case
or in the worst case you know in the
more PCS language right so you call the
worst case or in the most General case
this problem is not solvable
so
um finding the
AIS
are computationally hard
actually actually there are several
layers here as well if you want to
discuss the details you know in a very
worst case actually the the AI is kind
of unique you know have a unique
decomposition
and when the the composition is unique
you can also there are also cases where
the decomposition is unique but you
cannot find them you know computational
efficient way
um
[Music]
so
if you take a street you will play three
to be two
then it's pretty much like
um
symmetric
this this here is symmetric but you can
also make it asymmetric but yes you are
right it's basically new algebraic stuff
like FB
um
um and and this is a very good question
so I think
in some sense as you see like in some of
discussions below like in some aspects
the the tension conversation is kind of
close to metric decomposition
but
one there but there is a one fundamental
difference so that fundamental
difference is what enables
um that that makes this kind of tools
powerful but also challenging like like
it's powerful in the sense that it's
fundamentally powerful because
uh because here this is no there's no
no rotational environment
I guess this no rotation environment is
also you have to interpret in a careful
way so what I mean is that
sum of a i
tensor 3 is not the same as sum of
rotation of AI
1033
however this is true for
matrices so if you have sum of ai ai
transpose this is the same as sum of R
times AI or R is application matrices
um
I guess this is
I guess it depends on how you rotate it
um I think this how do I say this I
probably shouldn't say this on the flyer
without thinking about what's the best
way to
I guess I guess technology rotate on the
right so
so
um
so maybe let me not make it precise but
I think maybe one thing to to realize is
that if you have matrices you have a
times a transpose something like this
which is kind of like a sum of AI
transpose if you put all the AIS that's
Columns of capitalism
so then this is equals to A times R
times R A transpose if R is a rotation
Matrix Matrix and you just cannot do
this you know for the
for the tensors that often
so
um so but but what happens here is that
if you permute if you have ai
and you permute it
permuted indices
to
AI primes right where AI params are just
permutations of AI then the the the the
this resulting sum the third mode third
tensor is still the same
so you only have notations symmetry but
no
uh you only have permutation symmetry
but no rotation Symmetry and this is
actually make it somewhat powerful
because this in many cases this is the
case like for mix of gaussians you can
you can permute all the centers and
that's still the same gaussian but you
cannot rotate the chlorine systems to
make it the same you can't rotate the
at least you cannot take linear
combinations of the centers to to still
maintain the same mixture of caution and
and I think this also applies to large
works I think volumize works you have
the permutation symmetry where you can
permute the new the neurons in community
layers and also the associate edges
and you can still maintain the
functionality of the neurotrope exactly
the same
but you cannot do arbitrary kind of
rotations in it because you have the
nonlinearity with activations so
um yeah but I guess this part is
supposed to be somewhat abstract because
you know once you if you see a lot of
tech mass then you kind of probably
understand it's a little more better
um but anyway so there's some
fundamental differences between this and
and linear algebra so that's why cancer
decomposition becomes difficult
um
especially the worst case okay going
back to the um to the list of you know
questions you know so as I said the
the starting point is in a general case
you can you cannot hope to do anything
but there are many cases that where you
can do something so the easiest case is
the orthogonal case
so orthogonal case means that if A1 up
to a k
are orthogonals
so and in this case actually this is the
closest to the eigenvector case right
this is a so here you can say that then
a i is actually the global
each of these AI h of a i
foreign
is the global minimizer there are
multiple Global immunizers so that's why
each of them is a global minimizer
maximizer actually
of this objective function where you
maximize
the L2 Norm the maximize this
tensor paid by a Workman tensor so guys
if you're not familiar with the notation
then what I really means that you take
this sum of t i j k times x i x j x k
so this is the extension of the
quadratic performed for matrices right
so suppose you have Matrix then this is
the quadratic form and for tensor this
is this tensor form
and
so so so so so
eigenvectors can be defined in this way
you know if you change the tensor to The
Matrix because eigenvector is what
maximizing the quadratic form to The
Matrix so sometimes in this sense the
the components are some kind of like
eigenvector
and then you can find this
so this is a interesting property so
this is saying that AI is kind of like
kind of like eigenvectors
of t
uh and and also
we can find it you know it's not trivial
to find it but you can find
ai's employment
and and actually the way to find it is
that you decide to solve this
optimization and it's one way to find it
is that you try to solve this
optimization problem back with music
so that's one way one case and
another case is that okay more General
case that you can have the independent
case
so it turns out that if A1 up to a k
are linearly independent
then this is also good case you can find
this in polynomial time I think the
algorithm is for generation
I'm not going to describe all of this
algorithm just because it will take too
much time
um and in some sense these are things
that you can as long as you have some
kind of like
a basic knowledge you can search over
the literature and there's many papers
about this something
um
so but these are so one two are both
about under so-called under complete
case
one two
and the so-called
under complete
case which is really means that K the
number of components is less than b you
can see that
number one number two can only happen in
one case less than V because if K is
bigger than b there's no way that A1 up
to a n are linearly independent it's
because your number of components is
speaking of Dimension so they cannot be
linearly independent
but actually you can also do this for
over complete case over complete case
are still possible
but still possible
in certain cases
so there are several different ways to
deal with over complete case which means
K is bigger than d
so the first one is that you can look at
higher order tensors
so you can say that suppose
A1 tensor 2 up to a k tensor 2
are independent
this is a much relaxed condition than A1
up to a k are linear panel because now
you have higher dimension so so now this
this only this only requires you know K
needs to less than b square right less
than b squared to to make this possible
to happen
and suppose this is true then
you can just uh replace a I by AI 10 S2
so you can recover
AI
from
the six other tensor so you recovered
from area 10.42 to the tensor power
three
I'm from 1 to K
and which is still on the same as the
six of the tens
and how do you do it you just invoke the
third level tensor on AI to the power
two and then after you get a to the
power 2 you can get AI by just taking a
square root
so so this relax the the restriction on
the k
um but but you know somehow but with the
cost of estimating six moments because
how do you get this this is a thing with
in R to D to the sixth so you have to
somehow do something with the sixth
movement uh it will be less sample
efficient and well another slightly
clever way to do this is that you can do
fourth order tensor
uh with the same condition so so you say
that um
uh Sports all the generic tensor
and what does generic tension really
mean
it means that
you exclude
excluding
algebraic set
of measure zero so you exclude
a small set of you know a match zero set
of tensors and accept those kind of
cancers you can do this
and
and this is saying that when
K is less than b squared
you can recover
uh AI from
the first answer
right so before if you achieve your
reduction you get
um you get the third you need to use the
sixth order tensor but now you only have
to use the fourth hour tensor and this
algorithm is called Ruby
um
and you can also have a robust version
of this
this algorithm by itself is not robust
you can also have robust versions of
this
I guess let me not write down the the
references I'll I'll references later I
guess
if you just uh if I could just get the
initials I think these are some
references like this where you can get a
robust version of these algorithms
and and if you want to be
um more ambitious right so you want to
say that I want to even deal with third
double tensor then you what you can do
is you can say you have random
cancers
and by random it means that if you
assume
AIS
are randomly generated
um
for some unit vectors
I guess whether it's unibacters is not
that important but you know for
Community let's say they are all unit
vectors and they're all randomly
distributed on immunosphere
and then
for even third Auto tensor
uh
K can be as large as
equal 1.5
so so you can kind of overcomplicate
even with third Auto tensor
um and there are some references here
which I guess
I'll add it to the nose eventually
okay
Okay cool so this is just a very quick
list kind of probably a little boring
list of like a references uh but I guess
you see the rough idea right so you can
for various conditions but component AIS
you can
um you can have various kind of
algorithms and and different results
right so technically if you have more
restrictions on AIS you get stronger
results right so the strongest one would
be you have you assume they are random
then you can get uh you can even
decompose over complete tensors
uh of when the order is only three
um but if you don't have that strong
assumptions you have to go with the
phosphoryl tensor or even six hours
sensor uh if you don't use the right
isotope
so this is basically what's going on in
this area and and you can see there are
many many papers that deal with
different kind of like setups
um so so I write some references to the
to the to the lecture notes but
generally this is something you can kind
of search on internet and they are just
to before we conclude this part there
are other latent variables that can be
done
um
can be done
um by moment method on method the moment
using the same strategy where you first
complete a more money you turn it into a
tensor documentation problem so you can
do the so-called ICA in the component
analysis and the hidden Markov models
and you cancel the topic models
I think they are even more than this and
I'm just listing a few that are most
prominent so these are all living
variable models for Enterprise Learning
um and you can for each of this you can
try to compute certain kind of moments
and rearrange your moments so that you
get a tensor and then decompose the
tensor to construct uh the true parents
any questions
turned over cancer
so we want to Captivate
more General
technology
um I think Let Me Maybe I didn't let me
try to answer and then you can clarify
if I you know answer the question so I
guess the flow just is something that
you first start with the data you
compute some
tensor maybe this
or maybe false or maybe let's say four
here and you of course you cannot
compute this exactly you compute this
approximately
you you have some error in isolating
this fourth moment and you know that if
you don't have nany error then this will
be something like sum of AI to the
tensor for right from 1 to K and then
you decompose
you get AIS and I guess how does the
dependency kind of deep so where like
what the I guess one thing is whether
it's over completely under complete
right so
why does that matter that matters
because this K is what is K in the mix
of goals and K is number of mixtures
so if you can handle over complete
tensor decomposition that means that for
the original problem you can handle
more than these mixtures right your
number of mixtures you can handle is
more than dimension
um and if you can only do under complete
answers then your number of mixtures has
to be less than Dimension that's why
people care about over complete tensors
there's a lot of K the K here is
something fixed it's not about okay so I
guess there is another thing which is
K is the something you know
you know there's a number of mixtures in
your you know you know there's something
fixed considered right so what is
I guess maybe what you're asking is this
is the
is this empirical see
right so so the real thing is that you
work on this
and then you say this is approximately
equals to the sum of ax to the tensor
four and you decompose that approximate
version so you also need your algorithm
of your decomposition algorithm
to be your boss to some errors but
because you don't know exactly uh this
this thing this slogan tensor exactly
you only know approximate version of it
and I said I'm not answering the
question
go ahead you know maybe I'm not
answering about the right question
right
right lower you can think of cancer
organization as a low rank approximation
for the tenses yes
[Music]
[Music]
so all of these theorems so far I listed
you know they are all they are they all
work for all proximate version even
though I didn't really talk about the
approximate version
uh yet like I didn't talk about
approximately expensively right so so in
sometimes the kind of the the first
order best is that even you don't have
any approximation you get exactly a low
rep tensor
you have to be able to decompose it that
even that's now trivial right so for for
matrices it's trivial because you just
take SVD but for time service it's not
trivial so that's why the first element
is to say I get exactly low rank tensor
I can decompose it and then the second
question is the so-called robustness
which means that you get approximately
low ranked answer how do you decompose
it
um I think all of these algorithms I
think are robust there are some robust
version of them
so
um and and typically the if you don't
cover the optimal sample efficiency then
they're all robust just for trivial
reasons
but but if you really care about exactly
how many samples and how robust they are
it becomes a little tricky because you
have to talk about it sample efficiency
like the how does the concentration work
so forth
yeah you can kind of think of the AIS as
the largest eigenvectors
yes
you can roughly think of that idea
okay
okay cool okay sounds good so I guess um
Okay cool so then I'm gonna move on to
the last
subtopic you know in this in this course
I guess it's still about as fast
learning but it's about slightly
different type of ice Quest learning
which is a more like clustering and and
you can see that it's we are still doing
spectral at methods we're still doing
some kind of special decomposition but
but it's decomposing you know
slightly different way like you're I
guess I guess I'll you will see
um once I I formulate the problem and
you can see that before when you do the
tensor method you are building some
powerwise information between the
coordinates all all three of us
information between the coordinates of
the data right so here
from now on I'm going to talk about a
different type of approach where you
build paragraph information between the
data points
and then you do something on top of that
um so um so I guess I'll specify more
clearly so this spectral
clustering
so I'm going to discuss actually a bunch
of different
um algorithm or setups you know under
this this broad framework this kind of
whole spectral cluster kind of framework
I think is proposed by
um she and Malik
are out around 2000 I think also
uh wait
Andrew in Mike Jordan
and wife
in 2001.
maybe maybe this is 2016 I I will have
the references in the election notes so
it has been like 20 years old
um so so I'm going to kind of discuss
you know a bunch of like a classical
things like about this and also next
lecture I'm going to talk about one of
my own work which kind of is built on
top of this to get into a deep learning
case so to extend it to the people in
case
um
so the general idea is that suppose you
have
um
so we are given n data points
um let's call them X1 up to xn
and let's say we are given for the
moment let's say we are given a
similarity Matrix
and don't ask me how to get this just
let's just assume that we have a
similarity Matrix G
which is
of Dimension n by n you know actually
it's going to be a problem you know to
construct the similarity Matrix to some
extent but for the moment let's say we
will have this in some cases we do have
this similarity Matrix and this G where
each of these entries of this Matrix is
doing some
similarity is capturing the similarity
between two data points x i and XJ
here you know you can interpret this as
similarity or something like a sum or
just generally some makes you capture
some relationship between data points
um I think it's reasonable to think of
them as similarity
um so and the larger the more similar I
see
but this is not that important
so I guess you can see that this is what
I call the paragraph information between
data points but not Parallax information
between the coordinates
actually if you do
in certain cases they are they are kind
of the same
um but in some other cases they're not
the same
um
so so for example
um one example could be that
you have X either images
and then row x i
x j
measures the symmetrical
the semantic similarity of these two
images
how do you get this I think it's a
little bit kind of tricky because you
know typically you cannot just take the
L2 Norm to match the symmetric
similarity you know you because there
could be two images that looks pretty
different but there are simultaneously
similar
um but but for the moment let's assume
we're given such a matrix
uh such a similarity simulator Matrix
example two which is probably more
kind of like classical usage of this
kind of like models so where you can say
think of X is our users
of social network
and and the law of x i
x j is equals to one
if they are friends
like on Facebook let's say
um so so and when they are France it
means that they share some kind of like
similarities maybe similarity in jobs or
interests or
um or some other things right so you can
think of this as a similarity uh measure
between two users
and and eventually on the classify in
this case you want to eventually
classify the users into groups right so
you want to say
um I can I can detect trading
communities between users uh from this
unlabeled graph
um and so so basically the goal is to
the goal
is to do some classroom
to some kind of clustering
I guess maybe I should just just
clustering
clustering the
uh the data points
I guess in the
in The Social Network example maybe you
have like all of these users where you
have let's say
so many users and there's some
friendship relationship between them
something like this maybe
and then what you want to do is you want
to detect some so-called hidden
community so for example you can say
this is a cluster this is another
cluster and maybe this cost that
corresponds to people at Stanford and
these cluster corresponds to people at
Berkeley and right so of course between
Stanford students you have more
connections than between Brooklyn
students you have more connections and
there are some connections across the
groups and so forth
and I mean and in this case
um and also you know for example for
this example two you can think of this
also G as a graph
I think even in general case you can
view G as a graph but it will be a very
graph here G and this um in the social
network case and G is you know binary
because gij is binary so it can view G
as a graph and gij is an H
and your goal is to kind of
partition there are many ways to say
what your goal is right so you can say
you can you are clustering the data
points or you can say you are
partitioning the graph into different
parts uh so that each part has more
connections within each part you have
more connections compared to across
different parts
so
um so in sometimes you know this is
you can now view it as partitioning
to graph
into kind of like
um components
that are separated from each other that
are separate
from each other to some extent there's
no way you can
completely decomposted into completely
destroying Parts but you can somewhat
self decompose them
kind of like partitional graph into more
or less destroying parts
and so this is the kind of the general
type of setup
um I'm going to kind of like uh discuss
probably one or two instantiations about
this
um
so I guess
um the general theme is that
is the following so this is a I I feel
like this is a pretty deep kind of like
observation in math
um and the general kind of way to think
about to to to say this is that I get
decomposition
of this graph G
really relates a lot to the graph
practicing so again the conversation of
this agency symmetric G
here by G I really mean agency
symmetrics relate
uh to very well to the graph
partitioning problem
so you see that you know in all of the
examples I'm going to give you know the
main approach is to do some eigen
deformatization
um
and and actually sometimes it's not
economization of G it's either
transition of some
transformation of G
but the key point is that eigen
optimization seems to relate so much to
partitioning and clustering and it's not
that obvious but economic conversation
is very linear algebra
thing and graph partition is a very
common Authority thing and this is why
it's kind of like useful because when
you deal with combinatorial stuff right
my kind of
I'm not really a comatatorics person but
but my way to think about it is that you
know many commentary stuff you know once
you can relate to algebraic or linear
algebraic or or other kind of like
polynomials then
you get to you get exposed to a
different type of tools and you can do a
lot more things sometimes a lot more
things uh that you expect it
um
so this is the general thing and we're
actually going to see probably two two
or three examples to see
um uh why this is the case
um so I'm gonna so now I'm gonna do
something more concrete so this is
called stochastic model
this is a very concrete setup where you
can do math and you can say what's what
I mean you can instantiate what I mean
um uh clearly so so Mr stochastic blog
model I think this is a very related to
SPM
um and so G
is assumed
to be generated
randomly
from two
sometimes it could be more but I'm I'm
doing only two groups two hidden
uh
communities
or groups
so
so the setting would be something like
you have an vertices or and users and
you assume that there are two hidden
groups
as an Ice Bar
and this is the partition
meaning is and S Bar are disjoint
and then you assume that if you are from
two users are from the same hidden
Community then they are more likely to
be connected via Edge
so if I and J are both from us
or I and J are both from S Bar
then
the probability gij is one
with probability p
and zero with probability 1 minus p
and then if I and J and otherwise if ing
are from different
otherwise which means that they are from
different community
then gij
is one with probability q and zero with
probability one minus Q
and here importantly p is much larger
than Q
maybe that's it much larger for the
moment how much larger will Quantified
in a moment but you need P to be larger
than Q
let's maybe I'll just write larger but
not much larger
so basically
for from the same hiding group you have
a higher chance to be connected than
Edge compared to from a different
heading group
thank you
I guess you know if you draw this I
guess I don't know how to draw something
a random graph but I think you can think
of there is a s and there's a s bar
some edges and then if p is something
like probably close to one then you're
gonna have something like this
within the group you have high
probability to connect each other and
across the group you have some sparse
edges maybe just some righteous
okay so I know it's not the goal becomes
so the goal
is to recover
as
and as far if you cover as you can
recover as far from the gravity
right so
so this is a well-defined data
generation model and you want to
basically want to discover the hidden
groups right you want to do the
clustering
and and our approach is gonna be eigen
the conversation
so maybe before talking about eigen
implementation for some extreme cases
you don't have to do eigen conversation
right so suppose let's just do some kind
of like some more trivial warm-up right
so suppose peas
0.5 and Q is zero then you don't have to
do any
kind of like I think almost like you
don't have to do anything because you're
gonna see two disconnected parts right
so if p is 0.5 and Q is 0 you basically
have some s and that's bar
and you have some ideas not complete
connections you have some ideas here
and then there is a clear two Sub sub
graphs you can just basically kind of
like for example you can say I start
from this I look at all my neighbors and
I put them all in us and then because if
you see that you know that they are from
the same group right because if they're
not from the same group you have zero
chance to see a hatch right so basically
just need to see all the
all the points you can reach from this a
single point and you got all of this for
three points and then you declare that
GPS
and the same thing you can do it for the
other side you can do some kind of like
a just you can just try to
doesn't make sense I saw some confusions
I don't know like basically the
algorithm I'm going to do is the
following I started with a note and
let's see what what this node can reach
to
and I put it into my stacks and then I
do the repeatedly to see what other
nodes I can reach to
until at some point I I reached the
boundary I reach a closure I cannot
reach any new notes and declare this to
be and then I declare this to be us
so and and under the rest of the might
have to be as far that would work pretty
reasonably well for for piece plus five
and q0 and that's because you know
first of all you don't have any false
positive
because you know
like all the notes you discover should
be belongs to the same group because if
you're and second I think you can also
try to show that you you can't find all
the notes because if somebody is in your
same group it should connect to someone
right and then right someone you know or
like this is the so-called small world
kind of phenomenal right like if
if this other user is from the same
group they should be connected with you
by some classes press and pause so
um anyway so this is a but you can see
even for me to convince you this is
algorithm is work working for p is 0.5
and q0 is not that trivial you have to
do something right and this is a
commandatory algorithm and what we are
going to do is that we are going to do
um a more kind of like uh
uh linear algebraic type of algorithm
and you can see everything becomes kind
of even clearer and this is a more
powerful algorithm
um and and you don't need those common
reasonings
so
so what do we do so we basically just do
identification and as a warm-up what's
going to do is that we're going to do
eigenization
identity conversation
because how do I simply I can
decomposition
what's the right acronym for eigen
defensation
eigen decomposition
for
um for G bar which is expectation of d
so clearly so what is the biology bar is
the expectation of G so you you have a
weight and the weight is the expectation
of
uh the the you just take expecting of
gig
so uh clearly you don't have this c bar
but that's just for the starters let's
let's look at this expected version
right so and what is the expectation
what is this G bar i j
this is going to be equals to p
if I and J from the same class from the
same community
and and equals to Q otherwise
so that means that basically if you look
at this G bar
so suppose
this is the indices for us this is the
indices for S Bar this is Unity for us
let's define
so when you have both iron J from us
you'll get P to get PP like this
and here you get Q
so this is G bar
so and my claim is that
in this case
suppose you have to access to G bar
so the top eigenvector
of G bar is
a
is the all one vector
and
second the second eigenvector
of G bar is is interesting
is this x Vector where you have once
on the coordinates in s and minus one on
the corner in Ice Bar
so basically if you got the second
eigenvector of T Bar you solve the
problem because you can speed off the
community membership from from this
eigenvector
that's the click
okay
so
so it sounds a little bit kind of
interesting right like the proof
I guess what's the intuition here so I
guess the intuition
probably come probably come from the
proof so let's first do number one
number one is kind of like a almost
always true for for any uh funny cases
it doesn't even have to be such a
special G bar so so what you do is you
just say you you cut G times or one
vector
and what is g times over one vector
basically you multiply G with all one
vector here right something like this
and you modify it basically you are just
a
looking at the sum of the answers in
each of the logs right that was G times
one right so what's the sum of the
entries of each of those the sum of the
first row is something like P times n
over 2 plus Q times n over 2 because
there are n over 2 answers
with p and of two answers with value q
and every row has the same thing it's
just a
so this is equals to basically
simplify this p plus Q over 2 times n
times r one vector
so
so you can kind of see that Y is the top
eigenvector
actually even for more General
for General kind of graphs always graphs
so far
for any Matrix
with
fixed
row sum
or for any
graph
with so-called uniform degree
right the degree of a graph is really
literally the real sum of the GCC Matrix
right so how many ideas you have
connecting to each of the node vertices
that's basically the low sum
so so if if all the degree of our
vertices ever all the vertices is the
same that means the low sum of the
existence Matrix is constant and that's
that means that all one vector is uh the
topic vector so so this is a um so this
is a very interesting fact
um so so basically topic doesn't really
tell you much you have to go to the
second econometric to see the
interesting fix
so now let's look at the second language
so what I'm going to do is there are
many ways to to evaluate whether
this let's I think let's call this
Vector U there are many ways to to
verify U is an eigenvector right you can
directly you know multiply it and see
what's the eigenvalue I think the
probably the most intuitive way to think
about is the following so let's look at
G bar
let's subtract from T Bar a background
thing
sorry
foreign
over two
oh I guess sorry I I didn't I didn't
assume that my back I didn't assume that
this is a equal partition I should
assume that
so this is also possible to assume
also assume
as is an over two as bar is n over two
um if you're not equally related I think
you have to do a little bit
other things to to deal with it not
super important but
um yeah so if if the ISS bar are not
exact the same I think all one vector is
not the
I can do that anymore so you have to
really break you have to kind of like
massage this Matrix to you a little bit
to make it still true but that it will
talk we'll get to that in a moment
um in the next option I guess so
um but so far okay so let's assume is
bar balanced
and now how do we see the second eigen
Vector is this Vector U that we want to
look like we want we're looking for
right so so what the my way to think
about is that you you subtract G bar
uh is subject from G bar this background
Matrix one one transpose times Q so
basically the structure Q from this
every entry of this Matrix one one
transpose times Q is really just a
matrix with all
entries being Q
and then what's left is this Matrix
let's call it
let's say R is equal to P minus Q you
get r
something like this
so
right so this is us this is us as far as
bar
and here we have zero
okay so now you can see that this Matrix
becomes nice because it's a block
diagonal matrix
so for this Matrix if you want to verify
maybe let's call this Matrix G Prime
so we can verify G Prime Times U
is equals to U and how the verified is
equal to multiply of U how to verify
this this is just because you can do
this
for the two blocks separately right so
so this is really just a
something like r r
times you know well one
minus one minus one
all right so when you do these two
things separately and
and basically you get
uh R times n over two for the first
of two coordinates and you get minus r
times over two
for the second set of Corners so this is
R times over two times U itself
so and also
you
is orthogonal to all one vector
just because half of them are positive
half of the narrative so you take the
inner product it becomes zero
so so that's why if you even look at G
times G Bar times EU this is equals to G
Prime Times U
because the
the background you subtract of
is orthogonal 2 to U so that's why this
is equals to R times over 2 times U
which is
P minus Q over 2 times n times U
foreign
so this is the
so so I think the main point is that
after you subtract all of this
background thing
then this G Prime
is block diagonal
and this means that
the eigenvectors
um
Alliance
with the with the blocks
I think this is the kind of the
fundamental things that we are looking
for
and maybe maybe to just to generalize
this to to make it
looks a little bit kind of like um
more
convincing so suppose you have a matrix
a which looks like this
suppose you have some
answers one one here in this block and
you have
a lot of once
and you have a lot of ones here
suppose you have three blocks no it's
not two blocks
then because you have block diagnosis
you know that
for every block you can you can do your
own thing
right so then
if you look at
uh if you look at the eigenvectors you
can see that
you can see that this
foreign
so I got each of this
three vectors
are eigenvectors
because you can do each of the blocks in
a separate way so
right so I guess there is a
so so basically you can you can say that
so so if so you can say that I'm going
to choose the Allman Vector for the
first block and then zero and all the
other places that's still angry vector
okay
so and then
when you have this then you you have
that
um if you have these three eigenvectors
then the rows
if you look at every row here
[Music]
right so this is zero this is zero this
is one right so this row gives the
foreign
cluster ID
of the vertex
so each row gives you the cluster ID of
the vertex
so so I think this is the fundamental
intuition about why eigenvectors
are useful for capturing the
captioning the kind of factor
the classroom structure in the graph
it's just because in the extreme case
when you have extreme clustering where
so every
every block every stop side of the like
in this these three blocks or three
subsets they have like really just a
strong inner connections and no any
other cross groups Connections in that
case the eigenvectors is just strong
strongly below kind of aligns with
uh
strongly aligns with the
uh with the block structure
so and here I think like and then but
you see but but it was complicated which
makes things a little bit more
complicated that you have some
background right you have some more
things here and here right so some
random answers you know small entries
other places then it will change the it
will Elevate the entire Matrix a little
bit right but they wouldn't change the
eigen space fundamentally
that's pretty much the intuition
and then
questions
foreign
exactly why this is working right
because so the question is that what if
you permute this right
so if you promote it
it's kind of like you're promoting the
your eigenous vector will permute
accordingly
so suppose you have a
I'm not sure whether that makes sense
so so for example suppose you have
it
you you said you decide this part and
this part will be the first block
right and and and then this part
and this part will be the second block I
think your eigenvectors will permute
like the coordinates of the argument
will commit accordingly and that's why
it's aligned with the that's why the
alignment is kind of maintained and you
can discover the the higher structure
okay so
um
okay sounds good so I guess maybe maybe
another thing I'm not sure whether this
is a confusion for you like it could be
a confusion it could not like so here
the eigenvectors
there's no negative values in this
construction right
but but but it's kind of like the reason
is that the reason why I didn't have
negative value is just because
um it makes simpler because so for
example let's say even this Matrix this
vector
this is also eigenvector because it's
the sum of two eigenvectors and and all
of these arguments have the same
eigenvalue so any combination of diagram
I can still I go back that's that's how
you get the negative values so
um
um and and there's something special
about all one vectors okay because so
here there's like in this example in
this a example there is nothing special
about all one mattress because there's
no this background noise but when you so
what happens is that when you add
um a kind of a background noise to it
then the all one vectors becomes stands
locked
so so here you have three arguments that
are equally same but when you and all
one vectors is in the Subspace of these
three elements right so like all my
vectors is indeed a linear combination
of these three things
um
and when you add the background noise
the old one vector Direction stands out
and and then you are left with two other
directions which are still the same and
those two other directions will tell you
the the block structure
so so maybe maybe another way to think
about this is if you have two blocks
suppose you have two blocks
so if you don't have any background
noise then the eigenvectors will be one
on one zero zero zero
this is this will be a two I can access
but then when you're either back on and
you can you can represent this eigmatics
in two different ways right this is the
eigenag versus eigen system you could
also write it like this
just because you have different ways to
represent the two-dimensional Subspace
of econometrics but when you add the
background noise then this one will
stand out
so that's why you you can only write use
this system to to see it but not here
because
I'm not sure whether it makes sense
no
so so basically
without adding a background noise you
have two you have this direction
which is this one or one zero zero zero
and there's this direction
zero zero zero well online
and and also you can you can have this
direction which is the all one thing
and this direction which is the one one
minus one minus 1 minus one
so they're both so so so you have this
uh
two different sets of current systems
and
when you add background noise you you
you're gonna Elevate or you're gonna
increase the the strength in this
direction
but the Subspace doesn't really change
like like this direction becomes the
topic vector and this becomes the second
item
but fundamentally nothing really changed
that much
I hope this only clarifies Yourself by
computers
um okay so I guess I'm running out of
time
let's see
so I guess I'll take
two two minutes to
and I've gave a quick overview wrap up
and gave a quick overview what what we
do next so
so basically
you can also actually if you really want
you can verify
G is actually equals to P plus Q over
two times one
transpose plus P minus Q over two times
one
uh uu transpose
this is the the eigen decomposition of
this Matrix
um
so and
okay t-bar so next
what happens is we only have access so
in reality
we only have
G
so what do we do what we do is we just
say the intuition is just that
G is approximately equals to expectation
of G in certain aspects it's not true
that every entry of D is close to either
actually of expected G right because if
you take one entry G is binary and the
expectation of G is P or Q there's no
way they are close
but this is in terms of the
in terms of the spectrum
so so essentially you want to show that
essentially even though we need a little
trick to make this work nicely
essentially you want to show the
operator Norm between the difference
between these two is small
then
if either you use G to do the
decomposition so this means that
decompo
posing G is the same
is similar
through decomposing
expectations
that's pretty much and and now you can
see that the concentration in the
quality that we discussed in the early
lectures uh in this course becomes
useful
um so concretely what you do is the
following
so you take you write G
your G as G minus expectation G
plus expectation G extracting
expectation G is just G bar
and so this is G minus
expectation G Plus
p plus Q over 2
while my transpose plus P minus Q over
two
or one transpose
uh sorry new transpose
right so you want to say that this part
doesn't matter too much right it doesn't
really change your eigen spectrum
is the to make it cleaner what you can
do is that
uh you you subtract this part
because U is something you want to
discover top Elementor is something you
already know so so we probably shouldn't
ask in the top angle actor you should
just directly look for the second
eigenvector what you do is you sub you
move this to the left hand side
so you can get this p
you look at this Matrix
this is something you know because G is
something you know
and then this Matrix is equals to
this plus P minus Q over 2
. so you can review this as a
perturbation
right and this is something you you are
really looking for so basically you
start from the left hand side you take
an eigen decomposition
to do identity conversation
of G minus P plus Q over two
by one transpose and you hope that the
top eigenvector
of this Matrix is close to
and the hope is the top eigenvector
is close to you
that's basically our goal and and how do
you make sure that this is the two the
only thing so it suffice is to show
this G minus E G
in terms of the spectral Norm
is much much smaller than
the the the noise is much smaller than
that signal
in terms of the optional and this so
um so in some sense you need some
robustness of eigen decrementation I
guess I didn't really discuss any of the
existing theorems but but essentially if
you have this you can prove that
eigenvectors of the sum of these two
matrices is very similar to the
eigenvector of one of these Matrix
um and this is called Davis here I guess
now I wouldn't have time to talk about
all of this but but this intuitive
results makes sense right so if you know
it is small enough in terms of the
spectrum
and the option Norm then you get the
signal
um and so and how do you get this I
think we're gonna how do you so this is
true I think I'm gonna uh this I'm gonna
discuss that
in the beginning of the next lecture
it's essentially you just have to prove
some concentration according to using
some of the tools we had
um in lecture three or four of this
course
okay have any questions
so if you have more clusters the noise
will hurt the entire Spectrum right so
um and it becomes a little more
complicated so first of all if you have
no noise then you can still prove that
the eigen vectors are not for you to
recover the blocks
about the this robustness theorem will
be a little bit tricky because now you
have more eigenvectors and your noise
has an influence to each of them and you
have to control
you have to again control Some Noise to
Signal ratio in using some more a little
more advanced tactics
but but essentially the
yeah I think it's just really the
mathematical part it's a little bit more
complicated but fundamentally still
doing the same thing
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so I think that's that's a that's a
great question I guess just to rephrase
your question you are you are saying
that we do we really need to say that g
minus E G is small in all directions
do you just have to say that g minus E G
is only not messing up with the
direction that you I think you do have
to say
to some extent G minus E G is smaller in
all directions
um because if G minus CG is very very
big in One Direction I say even that
direction is completely orthogonal to
you let's say
then that direction will be a new topic
vector
right so because you're talking about
the max right you are not right
um but I think the like how do you
exactly measure this you know there's
there's still some room to negotiate but
but you do have to
in some sense say some something about
all directions to open noise
okay okay thanks I can see you uh on
Monday or Wednesday